foreign
[Music]
book in history no volume ever written
has been more loved and quoted and its
words sometimes simple and sometimes
mysterious should always be studied
carefully it is the Bible the word of
God welcome to Bible answers live
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your Bible questions
our phone lines are open if you have a
Bible related question give us a call
now at 800 God says that's
800-463-7297 now here's your host from
amazing facts International Pastor Doug
Batchelor hello listening friends would
you like to hear an amazing fact
as a child Andreas Russo used to listen
to his Peruvian grandfather tell amazing
stories of all boiling River hidden in
the jungles of Peru
then years later during his Graduate
Studies at Southern Methodist University
in Texas ruso was creating a thermal map
of Peru using infrared satellite
that's when he discovered an unusually
large hot spot one of the largest
geothermal features found on any
continent
in November 2011 Andreas Russo went to
Central Peru on an expedition and
discovered the boiling River for himself
in a remote jungle several hours from
the nearest city of pulcolpa Guided by a
local Shaman he saw for himself the
legendary boiling River
the steaming turquoise river is guarded
by 60-foot walls of lush green forest
and vegetation and it stretches for
almost four miles the water temperature
ranges from 120 degrees to a scalding
200 degrees fahrenheit hot enough to
poach an egg
some places the water reaches 16 feet
deep and in places the mud of the
riverbank is too hot to even walk on if
you fall in for even two seconds your
skin would be covered in third degree
burns
frogs and small animals that fell in
have discovered this lesson the hard way
you know friends I don't know anywhere
in the Bible where it talks about a
boiling River but you know the Bible
does talk about a Lake of Fire
and you can read about that in the Book
of Revelation some people talk about
this as hell but it's typically called a
lake of fire you read in Revelation
chapter 20 verse 14 and 15.
then death and Hades that means death in
the grave were cast into the Lake of
Fire this is the second death and anyone
not found written in the Book of Life
was cast into the Lake of Fire now there
are a lot of misunderstandings on the
subject of the Lake of Fire or Hill fire
and people go to one of two extremes one
group says there is no hell and the
other group says that the fires of hell
are going to torture and burn people
through ceaseless ages never-ending
boiling burning brimstone
actually the Bible tells us that every
person is punished according to what
they deserve that they are burnt up the
Bible says in Malachi they are turned to
ashes they are burnt up root in Branch I
just read in Revelation it calls it a
second death Jesus said you either have
the choice of life or you perish but the
idea of people being tortured endlessly
in the Lake of Fire is not a Biblical
teaching the Bible says God is going to
make a new Heaven new Earth where there
is no more pain no more sorrow no more
suffering all things are new Sinners are
not immortalized eternal life is given
to the saved not to the lost the penalty
for the Lost is death punishment and
death so many people have turned away
from God because of their
misunderstandings on the punishment of
the wicked you really need to know what
the Bible actually says
I mean I could go through the list of
people like Ingersoll and Karl Marx and
even Darwin one reason they turned away
from God is because they couldn't
conceive a loving God that would torture
the objects of his creation for all
eternity because of the sins of a brief
lifetime
would you like to better understand this
then we have a free booklet a study
guide that you need to ask for it's
called did is the devil in charge of
hell is the devil in charge of hell and
that's not of a a provocative question
that's what we want we would like for
you to ask for this free offer all you
do is ask for offer number 119 offer 119
call
800-835-6747 or you can simply do pound
250. and if you dial pound 250 in the
U.S and say you're listening to Bible
answers live they will send you that
offer and uh after you read it share
with a friend because it's it changed my
life helps it become a little easier to
love God and knowing that he is a god of
love well welcome friends to Bible
answers life uh tonight Pastor Ross is
returning from an overseas mission trip
and so while we're missing our regular
co-pilot but we're going to do our best
with the staff that's in the studio and
the Lord and we're going to go through
your questions as always we want to
begin with a word of Prayer
loving Lord thank you so much for the
opportunity to study your word with
friends like this and this technology
that makes it possible for us to do this
on a global level I pray you'll bless
this program that the truth will be very
clear and based on your word and just be
with us all we pray in Jesus name amen
I want to remind our friends not only
can you call in with your Bible
questions it's 800 God says that
translates into
800-463-7297 of course a free phone call
in North America and we are streaming on
the Doug Batchelor YouTube channel Doug
Batchelor Facebook amazing facts
Facebook and uh we're also broadcasting
this on um amazing facts Television
right now so it's not only radio it's
growing into more and more of a TV
program and we know some of our friends
at Hope Channel and better life are also
carrying this program uh sometimes
they're a delayed broadcast but uh the
questions are still real
so we're going to go right to the phones
now and got a call here from Anna in
Oregon Anna you're on the air with Bible
answers live
good evening Pastor Doug evening I was
wondering about the passage from Matthew
7 verse 6 pertaining to Casting your
Pearls Before Swine and are there
multiple meanings to this yeah Jesus
there says something that can be a
little shocking he said do not give that
which is holy to the dogs
unless they turn and run you and do not
cast your Pearls Before Swine
um you know I Think Jesus is telling us
there that there are people that will
monopolize your time and they'll try to
take you off the work that God has
called you to
and they're never going to change they
they have no interest in the truth
they're not interested in repenting and
reformation and a new life
uh even John the Baptist when some of
the Hypocrites came to his baptism they
weren't coming because they wanted to be
baptized they were spying on them and he
said you brutal vipers who has told you
to flee from the Wrath to come
so Jesus said uh you know there are
people that you can spend a lot of time
they want attention but they have no
intention of changing and you can spend
a lot of time studying with them and
working with them and
and there's people all around you that
are really hungry for the truth so when
you recognize that some ground is going
to be Barren go to where the ground is
fertile do not cast your Pearls Before
Swine your time your life is made of
time
and if you squander your time and let
the devil manipulate how you spend your
time
uh there's no shortage of people that
will just try and Gobble up your time
and there'll be nothing productive to
come from it so it's a tough statement
now you asked if there's multiple
meanings uh possibly but that's
typically the way I understand it
um is that yet you don't give what's
holy to the dogs
so thank you Anna I appreciate your
question
thank you you're welcome and all right
now we've got Glenn in Ohio Glenn you're
on the air with Bible answers live
thank you that Pastor manager thank you
for taking my calling it was a little
quip about your amazing fact that I I I
just wanted to
yeah if you do that that the the
eternality I guess was the incorrigibly
Wicked that it is the Eternal punishment
about eternal publishing and that anyway
thank you for taking the listening to
everybody my question is about prayer
my wife is the prayer warrior in the
family but I do pray I pray for
Thanksgiving and safety and I find
myself asking for a lot of things but my
question concerning people
who pray for a half hour some people
they talk about praying for two hours
what do people pray for for two hours
okay good well it's interesting you
would ask that question because uh the
length of prayer is going to be the
topic for My Worship in our office this
week and so I was studying that it seems
like when you read the prayers in the
Bible that public prayers are typically
pretty short
even the Lord's Prayer and I don't mean
where Jesus said you know Our Father
which art in heaven I'm talking about
when Jesus prayed in John 17.
um what we call the Lord's birth
technically the disciples prayer but uh
well Lord's Prayer is very short John 17
uh even that you can read it in I don't
know four or five minutes
but then the Bible does say that
um pray without ceasing now that doesn't
mean go around on your knees praying all
the time it means being an attitude of
communion with God Jesus did literally
spend entire nights in prayer for
example before he chose the apostles and
laid his hands on them he spent the
entire night in prayer so there are
times where on in personal prayer you
can spend a long time that doesn't mean
you're constantly talking to the Lord
during those times sometimes part of
prayer is you just wait on the Lord
You're bowing before him you're
listening you'll think of things to say
he might speak to your heart and it's
almost like you're having a conversation
and the Holy Spirit is speaking to you
and you're talking to God you're
thinking of people you want to pray for
I've got a friend that has a prayer list
and he knows that he'll forget to pray
for certain people that have requested
prayer so he makes a list and he will go
through his list with the Lord
uh so and I think some people actually
have a Ministry and a gift for prayer
that um
is special they're intercessors they're
prayer warriors
and not everybody has that gift
so I hope that makes sense public
prayers should typically be short Jesus
said the Hypocrites love to pray long
prayers but private prayers you may want
to pray longer in my personal prayers in
the morning I spend more time praying
than I would in a public for it
hope that helps a little bit Glenn and
uh thank you we sure appreciate your
question
and I appreciate it
is this can be effective the the
effectiveness is important thing is more
important than how long it is anyway
thank you for your answer and I wish
thanks so much God bless you and uh
talking next with Pamela in Louisiana
Pamela you're on the air
hello Pastor Doug how are you oh I'm
much better than I deserve every day
good well my question is what is the
special Resurrection is it before the
first resurrection
or is it the same as the first
resurrection well I think it happens
about the same time and for our friends
listening when we talk about a special
Resurrection
there are some people that were
participating in the crucifixion of
Jesus and at the trial of Christ Jesus
said I think he said it to Caiaphas the
high priest and Matthew
that Hereafter you will see the son of
man coming on the right hand of power
and so Jesus was telling the high priest
that he and others who
um
participated in crucifying him you read
in Revelation chapter one he's coming
into the clouds every eye will see him
they also which pierced him
so those that were involved in
condemning and crucifying him they're
going to come forth in a special
resurrection and they're going to see
that Jesus is coming as the Conquering
King
so that's one group and then there'll be
people I think that uh you know they
died uh in the faith of the Three Angels
message and sharing the good news and
God's going to bring them forth to see
the Promise fulfilled
so you know in the same way that there
are exceptions most people die and they
go to heaven at the resurrection at the
end of time but we know Enoch Elijah and
even Moses are exception so God
occasionally has exceptions when Jesus
rose from the dead some of the graves
around Jerusalem were opened and many of
the saints that slept were raised so
there are exceptions and the Bible seems
to have a couple of exceptions regarding
when he comes again
typically it's going to be the dead in
Christ that rise first but those
connected with crucifying him are going
to be raised to see that
thank you very much Pamela appreciate
your question
talking next with Bradley in Minnesota
Bradley you are on the air with Bible
answers live
hey Pastor
Jesus washed the disciples feet is that
something that we are supposed to
literally do to our fellow Believers as
a believer well I tell you what let's
look at what Jesus said and can I ask
you a question first
yes so you understand what the Lord's
Supper is communion yes
um do you think that's mandatory
yeah I think sometimes
okay so yeah you know Jesus commanded
that we should do that as often as we do
it it's a reaffirming our covenant with
him remember if you look in John 13
after Jesus washed their feet I'll look
at verse 12 John 13 verse 12 so when he
had washed their feet and taken up his
garments he sat down again and he said
to them now these are the words of Jesus
do you know what I have done to you you
call me Lord and teacher and you say
well for so I am if I then your lord and
teacher have washed your feet you also
ought to wash one another's feet for I
have given you an example that you
should do as I have done to you Jesus
uses the exact same wording that he uses
when he talks about the Lord's Supper
they said do this in remembrance of me
and here he says do what I've done
so in our church we practice foot
washing I know they do in a number of
other churches the Primitive Baptists
and and others they say hey this is a
pretty clear command now they may not do
it every time they have the Lord's
Supper we do in our church and some
Churches have communion every week in
our church where something like the
Methodist where they do it quarterly
just the idea is that you want to
reaffirm that Covenant it's important to
remind ourselves of that
but yeah I think that uh the foot
washing is a very clear command just as
with the others thanks so much Bradley
for your question
and we're with that we're going to talk
to will in Canada will you're on the air
with Bible answers live
good evening pasta good evening Michael
yeah
so uh my question is in Genesis chapter
3 verse 16.
and um the the final part of the curse
on the woman is this what does it mean
and is it still binding today okay let
me read this for our friends Genesis 3
16. this is after Adam and Eve fell they
send ate the forbidden fruit God then uh
curses both the man the woman and the
snake
and God says to the woman in verse 16 I
will greatly multiply your sorrow and
your conception in pain you shall bring
forth children and let me pause there
first is that still true yes first of
all he says your sorrow and your
conception conception isn't birth some
people have equated this with morning
sickness sometimes when a woman
conceives there's some sorrow and
sickness in connecting with that in pain
you'll bring forth children now of
course that's been mitigated a lot by
modern medicine but normally it's uh it
could be a joyful experience after the
baby's born but it could be a very
painful experience
in the delivery process
and it says your desire shall be for
your husband and he shall rule over you
and that's been understood to mean that
you might naturally want to rule your
husband but he shall rule over you
meaning that men were designed to be the
servant leaders in the family that's
where you get the word house band
husband
and men were to do providing
traditionally they're providing and
protecting
and so am I answering what you're asking
yes please but it looks like the society
nowadays uh women want to take the
leadership
yeah oh no no question about that the uh
the feminist movement I think has had a
definite impact on the church
Christianity and certainly the culture
uh typically uh commercials it's
expected that if there's a couple in a
commercial and if one of them is to be
made look to look foolish you're only
allowed to make the man look foolish if
you're uh if you make the woman look
foolish in some program or some
commercial that's called sexism so it's
a little different from when I grew up
and they had programs like fathers that
knows best of the traditional man being
a strong leader a lot of the media has
wussified the men in our society
all right Paul in Washington state Paul
you are on the air with Bible answers
live
hi thanks for calling
oh very very glad to call my question is
what does the Bible say anything about
why some people
um have a greater propensity to send and
other people have a lesser propensity to
sin
well that's a that's a fascinating
question
um first I'll answer yes
that I think that some do uh and it's
not that I think everybody's born with a
propensity to sin
um just because of our fallen Natures
but I think that in the rearing process
based on how some parents rear their
children if they are not taught
self-discipline and self-control then
children can grow up and you know they
constantly think the world revolves
around them and and selfishness which is
what sin comes from is very strong in
their natures
in his book
um James Dobson Dr James Dobson he wrote
a book about the strong-willed Child and
in his research he said it seems like we
are all given different characters and
some some children simply grow up and
they seem more willing to comply and to
please Authority
While others question and rebel against
every rule
and why that is I don't know but I think
we'd agree that even parents in the same
family the same mother and father one
will have a cane another will have an
able
and yeah so some that's the only
biblical example I can give you is that
yes clearly I think some seem to make
the wrong choices
a lot of it affects how they're raised
when they're very young I think it
Springs from that but good question I
appreciate that Paul thanks so much
all right Jerry in Texas Jerry welcome
to the Bible answers
hey thanks Pastor Doug a quick note I I
wish you guys were the area uh morning
prayer meeting that like you're going to
talk about the subject of prayer but
anyway okay my question is is that uh
I've asked you about this I think two
times and you know what's going to
happen in the future we really don't
know God is all encompassing you know
but in math Matthew 22 30 you know uh
when they asked about where there'll be
marriage in heaven yeah and uh you know
I guess you know I think there are going
to be gender neutral in heaven myself
that you know like a six-month pregnant
girl pregnant and you know Christ comes
in the sky some Glory uh she's going to
be a woman for a little bit and uh just
uh a few comments of that I mean holy
spirit gives you so much uh knowledge
and God bless that well thank you so
much but you've just touched on an area
that is somewhat mysterious
um I remember someone asked me during a
live program once what will happen to
women that are pregnant when Jesus comes
and I said without thinking they'll be
delivered
because of course that's a plan of words
but uh
I you know I think that probably they
will have their baby handed to them uh a
fully uh born you know a full-term baby
handed to them I can't imagine them
going through a painful birth in heaven
with their glorified body oh no because
yeah we get glorified bodies and there
are some things that are mysterious that
it's hard to explain uh and you know
what if I'm there I'll just be happy to
be there amen
you know no complaints for me
praise the Lord to be there hey thanks
so much dear I appreciate your question
oh thank you Doug bye good night all
right with that Archie in California you
are on the air with Bible answers live
hello Pastor
um
my question has to do with
people from eight years old to 80.
um
altering our life we have different
preferences
Jesus said love your enemies
well we have people we just don't like
others we say we hate
maybe we do maybe we don't but my
question is how do you obey Jesus and
love your enemies or love the ones you
don't like
you know it's very hard to do that
without the holy spirit because just
like you you know I've I've had people
that have hurt me and done things that
are mean and unkind and and then you
read where Jesus says I want you to love
them for one thing uh sometimes I'll
pray for a person even though I may not
feel like it because Jesus commands it
and I find that even as I'm praying my
heart softens towards them the other
thing that helps me is I realize that
sometimes people do mean or unkind
things because they're lost and that is
normal behavior for a lost person
and if they would be saved they'd be a
lot more likable
and so you want to pray that these
people the holy spirit will work on
their lives and change them and I have
seen folks that I didn't care much for I
had some conflict with and then the Lord
got a hold of their hearts probably also
got a hold of mine and uh you end up
becoming friends
uh God can change people
so I think that we're loving people to
be Redemptive and uh because Jesus loved
us even while we were unlovable even
while we were sinners Christ Jesus died
for us so we're trying to be like our
master and it's not always easy he says
sometimes you're taking up a cross
would he would it be possible for you to
write a booklet about this
I think everybody needs to know you know
I do have a book I just finished uh last
year you may not have seen it because we
haven't said much about it but if you go
to the Amazing Facts website I've got a
book on forgiveness
and uh the whole book is talking about
how do you forgive and it talks about
also how do you love some people that
are unlovable and if you call the
amazing facts resource line that's
800-835-6747 or simply go to pound 250
you can dial pound 250 on your phone and
say you're listening to Bible answers
live and it'll prompt you on how you can
get the offer for tonight and you might
also be able to record that you're
looking for pastor Doug's new book on
forgiveness and hopefully that would be
a blessing let's see can we get one more
call in
Nathan calling from Washington I think
we got a young person here Nathan you're
on the air
hello hi
your question hi
um so my question is when did they
become more than one language because in
Genesis 11 it talks about Babel and how
God can find the language but in Genesis
10 verse 5 it says by these were the
Isles of the Gentiles divided in their
lands everyone after his tongue after
their families and in the Nations so
when were when did they become more than
one language okay very good well you're
right Nathan they're at the Tower of
Babel in Genesis 11. they were making
this Tower sort of a monument of
rebellion against God and God confounded
them now the what happened is all of a
sudden they couldn't understand each
other
and the whole building project just
unraveled and fell apart in chaos people
began to group together
with others they could understand
and I think right then and there God
just made it where some people were able
to understand and communicate in groups
with others and the main languages of
the world were sort of born then now
language constantly changes and as you
go around the world you can see examples
of that a lot of languages are similar
but they're not the same I worked with
the Navajo Indians and their tongue was
very much like some Eskimos up in Alaska
and but not like the other tribes around
them study of language is a fascinating
business well I hope that helps a little
bit Nathan I appreciate your question uh
friends we're going to take our mid-time
break don't go anywhere because we're
going to have more Bible questions just
give us a call 800 God says we'll get to
your question in the second half and be
right back
foreign
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
what if you could know the future
what would you do
what would you change
future you must understand the past
Alexander the Great becomes king when
he's only 18 but he's a military prodigy
150 years in advance Cyrus had been
named
Rome was violent they were ruthless they
were determined this intriguing
documentary hosted by Pastor Doug
Batchelor explores the most striking
Bible prophecies that have been
dramatically fulfilled throughout
history Kingdoms in time
are you ready
Doug Batchelor was the teenage son of a
millionaire father and show business
mother yet he was living in a cave he
had everything money could buy
everything but happiness but all of the
fun and excitement he enjoyed left his
life out of control his search
eventually led him to a cave above Palm
Springs that became his home while Doug
scavenged for food and garbage bins his
father owned a yacht a Learjet and an
airline but in his cave home he
discovered a dust-covered Bible as he
began to read he soon learned of his
true purpose in life
richest caveman is the extraordinary
true story of Doug Batchelor that tells
how a rebellious teenager who once lived
in a cave became a tremendous Soul
winner for Jesus Christ it's a thrilling
testimony of the transforming power of
God's word to order your copy of the
richest caveman call
800-538-7275 or visit afbookstore.com
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
[Music]
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian Life call us now
at 800 God says that's
800-463-7297 now let's rejoin our hosts
for more Bible answers live
welcome back listening friends through
Bible answers live and this is a live
International interactive Bible study we
invite you to call in with your
questions you can simply call
800-463-7297 that's 800 God Says with
your Bible questions we're also
streaming this on the amazing facts
Facebook page the Doug Batchelor
Facebook page it's on Amazing Facts
television better known as aftv and you
can watch that online
aftv.org as well as the Amazing Facts
YouTube channel and we're going to go
back to the phones I am Doug Batchelor
Pastor Ross is coming back from a
mission trip tonight so we are flying
solo right now but we're going to talk
to Brent who is listening and been
waiting patiently in South Korea Brent
you're on the air with Bible answers
live
hello Pastor Bachelor um good to talk to
you I have a little bit of a research
question I uh I wondered if you could
explain the the disruptive discrepancy
in time between uh Genesis 15 13 and
exodus 12 40. um in in Genesis 15 13 is
where God tells Abraham that his
descendants will be slaves and strangers
in a foreign country and that it'll be
400 years and exodus 12 40 when they
come out it's I believe about 430 years
I I was merely wondering about that
discrepancy yeah good question that's
come up often as people are reading
through the Bible it's understood that
in Exodus there when it says 430 years
it's counting back from when Abraham
entered the promised land and God first
speaks to him in Genesis 12. he is 75
years old the other reference is when
the persecution begins and they're
starting that from when you know Abraham
was not supposed to marry Hagar the
Egyptian
and her son Ishmael was mocking Isaac
when he was five years old he was being
weaned
and this so they mark it there saying
400 years from the persecution that
began with Ishmael and then that kind of
surprised me when I first read it but I
read several Scholars that say that's
where it starts the children of Israel
were not in Egypt 400 years this is
where a lot of people get mixed up they
were not slaves for 400 years
you can read where I think Levi is the
father or grandfather of amran the
father of Moses you don't get 400 years
in those three generations
and they were probably 200 230 years
actually in Egypt in slavery
and but it's dating it back from when
the persecution began with Ishmael to
The Exodus so that's the that's the
understanding that I've had and I think
you'll find in some of the commentaries
thank you Brent and thank you for your
patience
all right talking next with is it
Shanika in Florida
have a good night um
my question is
the term soul mates is it biblically
linked or is it more of a worldly term
well I don't think you find the word
soulmate in the Bible but the principle
is there the a particular person that
God has designed for you to be uh your
spouse where your souls are knit
together
um and I think you can say yes
now when you say soul mates you know we
often think about a husband and wife but
when you read about uh there are friends
in the Bible that are soul mates and you
can read Jonathan and David it says
their souls were knit together
and so you could probably easily argue
Jonathan and David were soul mates and
some people try and build it into being
some kind of a homosexual relationship
which is absurd they were both married
and and very clear on that point but um
when you look at how God found a wife
for Isaac she was specifically chosen
elies of the servant went and he must
have chosen uh with the leading of God
because when Isaac saw her they fell in
love he never married another wife and
it says he loved her
and so it seems that and then later you
can see there's even a place where it
says that they're flirting with each
other even after they're married so they
seem to have a great love relationship
even though they uh had favorites one
favorite Esau and the other one favorite
Jacob
uh you could probably find other
examples I mean I think God was very
particular that Joseph was to be
the um the husband of Mary
and they seem to have a a soulmate Bond
God chose them to be the perfect parents
to Earthly parents I should say to raise
Jesus so in principle I think you could
argue that there are some people their
souls are knit together
when Jesus sent out the apostles
preaching it seems that Jesus paired up
the apostles two by two
where he was matching their characters
and John always seems to go out with
Peter John the brother of James I used
to thank the Lord why didn't James go
out with his brother John why didn't
Andrew go out with Peter but no Peter
went with John
and I Think Jesus matched up the twelve
and he put him two by two based on their
personality so that they would be
stronger together
um yeah so great question and thank you
so much thank you God bless Shanika
all right with that we're going to go to
Illinois and talk with John John you're
on the air with Bible answers live
good evening good evening
fantastic uh so Mike my Crescent is
regarding
um
Revelation 17 3 and 4.
um uh in the Scarlet woman yeah
um so it it says that when John was
taken away in the spirit to see her he
was taken into the Wilderness and in
Revelation 12
um uh God's church or God the woman
that's uh Dressed in the sun was uh
given Wings to go into the wilderness
that was just regarding that I was you
know I was doing the study on that and I
was wondering is that the same church
but corrupt as well as
um the woman's color what she was
arrayed in so it was a purple
and Scarlet but
um in Exodus 39
um the priest is also in that same color
but he has the color blue right and
that's the color of represents the Law
correct yeah the Bible does say that uh
the color blue was to be on the Hem of
the garments a reminder of The
Commandments let me read this for our
friends that are listening because I
always like to remember that a lot of
our listeners are driving or they're
preoccupied and they can't always drop
what their name and read the Bible so
let me uh we're reading Revelation
chapter 17 and I'll read verses three
and you said four
so he carried me away in the spirit Into
the Wilderness and I saw a woman sitting
on a Scarlet Beast which had names full
of blasphemy having seven heads and ten
horns and the woman was arrayed in
purple and Scarlet and adorned with gold
and precious stones and Pearls having in
her hand a golden cup full of
Abominations and the filthiness of her
fornication of course it goes on to say
her name is Mystery Babylon the great
the mother of harlots so a woman in
Bible analogy is a symbol for the church
and so this woman she is the antithesis
of the woman that you see in Revelation
12 that is clothed with the sun moon and
stars all natural light this woman is
clothed with artificial colors and
adornment it calls her a harlot
uh that's you know pretty Tell-Tale that
if she was once faithful she's not now
it is true God sometimes told his church
he told Israel you read the book of
Hosea he says you've played the Harlot
whenever God's people went after other
religions or other gods or Idols he's
called it harlotry
God said I'm your God I'm your husband
and here you're committing adultery with
these other gods
so the woman in Revelation 12 was
Christian or has at least some illusion
of being Christian but has uh
compromised
most Protestant commentators believe
that this is speaking of the papacy and
the Catholic Church what happened during
the Dark Ages when they turned to
idolatry of course they had the the
colors of the Cardinals are red and the
Bishops are purple and there's a golden
cup in the hand of the Pope and the
priests when they do the mass and
virtually all Protestant reformers
identified this woman with a Christian
Church that had compromised with the
Roman religion hence Roman Catholicism
but and they drifted from the Bible and
of course there are millions of very
faithful people in that church living up
to the light they have but nonetheless
the organization has drifted from the
scriptures
so um when you look in Revelation 12
you've got this Dragon this Scarlet
dragon that is trying to devour The
Other Woman here the woman is sitting on
the Dragon
so the the government of Rome tried to
destroy Jesus as a baby that's the
dragon there but now this woman is
sitting on the dragon and you can also
read it says in uh the last verse in
chapter 17 of Revelation the woman that
you saw is that great City that Reigns
over the kings of the Earth
well that was roll rome had imprisoned
John on Patmos now so for friends who
were hearing this for the first time
this is nothing new with me this is what
all Protestants used to believe we have
a lesson we'll send you for free and
it's called The Other Woman and all you
have to do is call
800-835-6747-800-835-6747 or you can do
pound 250 and when the answer say you're
listening to Bible answers live dial
pound 250 on your phone and that's for
those that are in the U.S and U.S
territories in Canada and we'll be happy
to make these studies available to you I
think you can even go to the Amazing
Facts website and read that study guide
on Babylon the mystery woman and you'll
get that information thank you very much
and we're going to go next to
Chris in Florida Welcome Chris you're on
the air with Bible answers live
hey Pastor thank you my question's on
the remnant Church okay and I was
wondering are is our church The Remnant
now before the close of probation
and the end of The Three Angels messages
or we make up the remnant church after
that time has passed and the coming
Sunday law is enacted
all right well let's talk about that
when you say the word Remnant church now
this is a biblical term if you go to
Revelation 12 and you go to the last
verse it says there in verse 17 the
dragon was enraged with a woman and he
went to make war with the remnant of her
sea now woman's a church it says the
remnant the remainder what's left of her
descendants that keep the Commandments
of God and have the faith of Jesus so
it's understood there by many Christians
that near the end of time God is going
to have a faithful remaining Church they
are going to believe the teachings that
were once delivered to the Saints they
will return to the purity of Bible truth
and Christ is not coming for a church
that has totally been dissolved by and
deluded by compromise he's coming for a
church that is revived filled with the
Holy Spirit they've been empowered by
the latter rain and I believe that's a
group that is still coming together now
but uh
I'd say you need to find a church that
follows the Bible the most accurately
and be part of that church to make sure
you're in the remnant Church says she
keeps the Commandments of God they
believe in all the Commandments that
means all ten
and they have the faith of Jesus you
read in Revelation chapter 14 12
Revelation chapter 12 17 it says they
have the testimony of Jesus that means
the law and the prophets they believe
the word of God hope that helps a little
bit uh Chris talking next to Bob in
Washington Bob
your name is the same forward or
backwards you're on the air with Bible
answers live
hello Pastor Doug evening how are you
not too bad a lot better afternoon for
sure okay well good we're glad you're
all rested up and your question tonight
um well it has to do with John 9 verse 2
um I've
I've talked with some people who believe
uh that that verse somehow they make it
into uh
um there's this one church that talks
about us being in a pre-mortal state
kind of thing
um right so they believe that um
that well the verse says his disciples
asked him saying Rabbi who's Sin this
man or his parents that he was born in
line so did the blind man sin before he
was born right yeah let me explain that
for our friends that are listening Jesus
you have to almost read the first verse
Jesus is passing by he sees a man who
was born blind from birth the disciples
begin to ponder why is he suffering if
he was born blind somebody must have
sinned for him to suffer like this what
did he do and so the disciples were
speculating keep in mind the disciples
their theology was not all right they
totally misunderstood Jesus mission so
you don't want to get your theology
totally from their questions because
they're still learning and they said who
sinned maybe his parents sinned or maybe
was it his sin and what they're saying
is God knew in advance this man would be
sinful so he punished Him in Advance
and uh and then you're right there are
people that say that you had some kind
of
pre-incarnation existence and in your
spirit body you were sinning or in your
pre-incarnation they had some form of
reincarnation and yeah there is a church
that believes that you exist without a
body before this Earth that's totally
unbiblical so the disciples are just
they're pondering and who sinned did God
know he was going to be bad and he
punished Him in Advance was it his
parents and then Jesus answers as it
says here neither this man or his
parents sin but that the works of God
should be revealed and of course he
heals the man
uh all thickness you know the people
that are born sick my brother was born
with a uh ultimately a terminal disease
called cystic fibrosis and he didn't do
anything wrong
and he struggled with it and and my
parents couldn't control their genes so
it wouldn't be directly from their sin
it could all be traced back to the sin
of Adam in the beginning has you know
caused sin and sickness and degeneration
through the whole Human family
good question Bob appreciate it thanks
so much and talking next to Nicholas is
that in Delaware
Nicholas you're on here
hi I'm
Senate's wild number of stars does that
mean the N can't come until Abraham
sends outnumbered Stars
no that I think is a figure of speech
God uses allegories you know God says I
own the cattle on a thousand hills if I
was hungry I would not tell you well God
is not eating barbecue
he's just he's just saying that
you know I own everything in the world
so when God tells Abraham your
descendants will be like the stars of
heaven and other places has like the
sand on the seashore God is not
specifically counting every grain of
sand and saying when Abraham gets as
many descendants well you know how many
grains of sand there are it's
innumerable there's a lot yeah and how
many stars are there they figure there's
almost as many stars as there are grains
of Sands it's innumerable
and so God is just saying that Abraham
would have so many descendants that you
wouldn't even be able to count them and
that actually came true during the time
of King David David wanted to number
Israel and they never even got the whole
number
but uh you know
joab said uh to David you know may the
Lord multiply your people a hundred
times more
but we don't even need to count them
anymore there's so many
so
um yeah I don't think God's waiting
until he's got as many Jews in the world
as there are stars in the sky
I think it's a figure of speech
okay that's what I thought but thank you
all right thank you Nicholas appreciate
your call
and with that we're going to talk to uh
Isaac
Isaac you're on the air with Bible
answers live
hey how you doing Preston doing well
good I had a question
um so why did god require land
sacrifices by his people after sin and
to the world because obviously like
in you know before sin there was there
was no death so I was just wondering why
would he require lame sacrifices after
sin
well you're saying why would he require
them after sin
yeah like I have to send into the world
wasn't he I guess requiring lamb
sacrifices by his people yeah you know
it dates back and you you can read in
Revelation it talks about the lamb slain
from the foundation of the world and if
you look in the Garden of Eden when Adam
and Eve first sinned they discovered
their nakedness they went and got fig
leaves to cover their nakedness and to
hide their shame God said that will not
do and it says so that they made aprons
of leaf the word that's in Hebrew was
they made aprons miniskirts and then it
says God made them tunics those are
Robes of skin
now where did God get the skin did God
just you know blink his eyes and all of
a sudden they had leather coats or did
God establish the sacrificial system
back there to explain that to cover
their shame something had to die
and those Lambs or goats that were dying
in the sacrificial system they had to be
clean animals they couldn't offer a
skunk or a pig or anything
the clean animals that died in the
sacrificial system
were a symbol for the day when God's son
would come what did John the Baptist say
when Jesus walked by the Jordan he
pointed to him and said Behold the Lamb
of God that takes away the sin of the
world all of those animal sacrifices
pointed to when Jesus would come and it
was reminding them that the blood of
Christ would cover their sin
so uh
it was a symbol and God used it to
educate people about the awfulness of
sin
yeah that makes perfect sense I never
heard anyone break it down like that
thank you all right thanks so much
appreciate your question and with that
we're gonna talk to Tammy in California
Tammy you're on the air with Bible
answers live
hi Pastor hi this is Tammy from Loma
Linda and my question is I know in the
Bible I forgot exactly where but the
Lord says that he had Jesus mentions
that he had given us power and authority
to cast out demons and to heal the sick
yes he says that Mark 16. he says it in
several places but one is Mark 16.
okay and so my question is
um is that
what we should be doing today
well does God still have the power yes
should we still pray for people that are
harassed by the devil or sick absolutely
uh do we have the same power the
apostles had no
uh will God pour out the holy spirit
before Jesus comes back and give that
power again yes
so there are times in history where we
see God's spirit and power moving in
different waves and different
intensities and before Jesus comes back
I think he's going to pour out his
spirit in the power of Pentecost and you
will see
Christians Believers going out doing
some of the same signs and wonders that
Jesus did
even Jesus said these Miracles that I've
done greater things than these will you
do because I go to the father
so I believe all that's literal I think
even today we should be praying that
people are delivered from the devil when
they're being harassed or possessed I
believe that we should be praying for
people who are sick and I've seen
miracles
uh just this last week someone asked me
to pray for somebody that was in a very
dire condition in ICU last report I got
is they had improved and they're out of
ICU now it doesn't mean it happened
instantly but I believe God heard the
prayer
so yes we should be praying more thanks
so much Tammy uh we're going to talk to
Jasmine in Texas Jasmine you're on the
air with Bible answers live
are you there Jasmine in Texas
hi hi good evening good evening yes hi
this is Jasmine um thank you so much for
taking my call yeah I was I was
wondering um my family and I have the
conviction and know that we are called
to live you know to live in the country
and we've been praying about it but
we don't know
how do you know when God is telling you
where because I know that if we're being
led by God then we won't fail but I
don't know where he's leading us how do
you know that oh that's a great question
and it's a very important question you
don't want to make the wrong decision
and I would say don't do anything unless
you do know with confidence that God has
opened the door
um first let me tell you there is a free
booklet that you can download or request
from amazing facts and it's called
determining the will of God and I give
12 points in that book
biblical principles about how do we know
God's will in a question not whether you
know we should kill or not kill I mean
there's sometimes many good choices we
wonder how do I know what God wants me
to do
um so that book is called determining
the will of God you can just go to
amazingfacts.org look at our Free
Library you can download that and read
it or you can call 800-835-6747
but uh
I I would look for providental openings
um you want to make sure before you're
going to like move to another country
you've got income the Bible tells us you
know to look ahead be wise in decisions
that you make and uh you know God
doesn't always ask us to just recklessly
step out in faith I've known some dear
people that said I feel like I need to
move the country and they quit their
good jobs they moved off with no
training or experience
they realized that they bought the wrong
piece of land and they came back to the
city bankrupt it was very sad I've seen
it happen a few times so plan carefully
and make sure God's leading you not only
does God show you what he wants you to
do sometimes he has you wait until the
right time
I mean look how long he had Moses wait
for his big mission and Abraham to have
a a son was Sarah so be patient and say
Lord we're willing to do your will now
here's the promise
once we tell the Lord we are willing to
do whatever he wants he then becomes
responsible to show us
if we are seeking we're knocking we're
praying we're asking he will show us
and so uh get Christian counsel look for
providential openings the leadings of
the Holy Spirit most importantly look in
the word and you'll find guidance in the
principles that are in the word of God
and download that book determining the
will of God and I think you'll be
blessed by that thank you Jasmine we
appreciate your your question now for
our friends that are listening uh you
know we're starting to come to the tail
end of the radio program right now and
I'd like to just explain to people that
when we sign off we are both on
satellite across the country satellite
radio and we're on land-based stations
they operate on a different clock but we
don't want to lose any of our time so
what we do is we sign off in two stages
uh after we sign off with our satellite
stations don't go away you're going to
hear me come back and I'm going to
answer some internet questions that came
in and if you ever have any internet
questions some people say I've got a
question but
um I'm afraid to get on the air some
people get nervous calling in a live
program and don't be but if you are you
can email us a question just go to
amazing facts and I think there you'll
see amazing facts it'll be backslash
Bible answers live and Dot org and you
can submit Bible questions there just
even if you go to the
amazingfacts.org channel you'll see
there where you can submit a Bible
question and for those of you that are
bidding us farewell driving down the
road God bless you we look forward to
studying with you again next week for
the others standby
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California
[Music]
we are back friends with some of the
internet questions that have come in and
thanks for standing by and uh let's
start with
um talora would like to know if we will
still have our old thoughts when Christ
returns and we are changed and the Bible
tells us in the book of Isaiah says the
former will not be remembered or come
into mind and he doesn't mean you're
brainwashed you don't remember that
Jesus has saved you but the former
painful memories that we have those
things are going to be eclipsed by the
Everlasting glory and Bliss of Heaven
you won't need to worry about that there
and so no you don't have to worry about
the painful memories and keep in mind as
time goes by time is healing our minds
are going to be so full of the
incredible experiences of Heaven that
all of the painful things of this world
are going to just be crowded out and
we're going to be looking forward Paul
said forgetting those things that are
behind I press on through eternity the
only reminder of sin will be the scars
in Jesus hand for what he paid for us
Kyle would like to know how will we know
when it's Sabbath in the new Earth if
it's they'll be neither day or night
well you know it doesn't say there'll be
no day or night it's talking about the
New Jerusalem it says there is no no
need of the Sun in the New Jerusalem
because the presence of God is there and
the Bible says God is light
the people sometimes say when when God
began creating the world he said let
there be light but he doesn't make the
sun till the fourth day but he has day
and night before he makes the Sun how do
you have day and night well God we set
the spin the planet spinning whatever
side of the planet was aiming the glory
of God the Bible tells us in Mark
chapter 9 and the Mount of
transfiguration the glory of Jesus was
brighter than the Sun and you can read
in Malachi it says then the son of
righteousness will arise with healing in
his wings so the light of God will
illuminate the city but the world will
still have a day and a night and they'll
still be weeks and it says from one
Sabbath to another All Flesh will come
and worship before him okay a nelly from
Kenya asks if it's acceptable to use
Family Planning methods uh I without
going into detail I would say yes the
Bible tells us do not build a tower if
you are not able to complete it and if
you cannot afford to rear a family
educate and be a good father or mother
then you ought to plan accordingly but I
don't believe in abortion I think that
what you should do then is prevention
and I won't go into detail there oh it
looks like we're out of time hey friends
there's so much more amazing thanks has
to offer please go to
amazingfacts.org watch us on YouTube and
Facebook God bless we'll study next week
bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]